[Music]
do you know where you are I'm in a dream
and now this
[Music]
could do this math squeeze again you
ready to man up now wait for it you're
gonna wake in three two oh yeah [ __ ]
who isn't part of the ambitious stupid
[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie surprise Game
of Thrones promo so these are actually
two different promotes that I just
mashed together one was like a longer
HBO promo that I just cut down to more
of the Game of Thrones footage and the
same thing with the second one it's just
sort of a tongue-in-cheek way to promote
the new costumes and the new characters
so we get a little bit of new footage
but if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything
I do Game of Thrones videos every week
there's even a giveaway going on I'll
explain at the end of the video but the
first new footage just focuses on shots
of Jon Snow Sansa and Arya that we've
seen before slightly more high-res Jon
Snow in Sansa are at Winterfell you can
see her walking in front of the weirwood
here with a slightly different costume
there's a much better look at it in the
oh [ __ ] promo it's hard to tell where
Arya is she's on horseback so it seems
like she's heading back to Winterfell
but there's no context you're just
looking at the sky that's the reason
they included that particular shot just
to make you wonder because normally they
continue it you just pan around and look
at whatever it is that she's looking at
but all the other stuff in that first
part of that promo is from season 6 so
this is Daenerys in episode 10 shall we
begin
this is Jon Snow Battle of the bastards
very memorable very easy to spot what
season six footage in what season 7
footage the second part of the promo is
just like one continuous oh [ __ ] from
all the different actors on all these
HBO shows all these main cast members
you see Jamie looking at his gold hand
scared oh [ __ ] oh my god then you see
tormund Giantsbane completely opposite
context like he's really excited oh [ __ ]
this is going to be amazing you get a
better look at sauces costume it was
sort of covered up at the end of last
season it's sort of a stark version of
the black costume that she wore at the
end of season 4 after Littlefinger
killed Lysa by pushing her down the moon
door you see brands version of the aw
[ __ ] while he's working but he's got new
Birds on meaning that he's either made
it to the wall and they've got him some
fresh clothes or he's made it to
Winterfell and that's where he got these
fresh clothes from so we'll talk about
that in a second but the only two
characters that are sort of like
off-model with the aw [ __ ] are Jon Snow
in Daenerys so Daenerys doesn't say
anything she just like points up and you
waiting you hear the dragons scream in
the background that's her version of aw
[ __ ] because the dragons of season says
are supposed to be as big as jumbo jet
so it'd be like living near the airport
you would hear them way before you'd
ever see them and then John snow shushes
everyone like be quiet but I do love the
look at the nurse's costume it's the
best look so far we've already seen John
snows costume at the end of season six
that's the one that salsa made for him
it's made to be just like ned stark's
you Trish made it myself she liked it
it was a lot the wolf did good because I
made this I made it like the one father
used to wear near as I can remember
Thank You sensei
you're welcome so most of the Maine
young characters on the show are
starting to look more and more like
their parents especially Sansa with her
red hair they actually sophie Turner
came to set and freak the producers out
because she still had blond hair from
another movie that she'd been working on
so they were like oh my god because
she's supposed to look more and more
like her mother as she gets older that
doesn't necessarily mean that she's on
the same auric like she's going to
become Lady Stoneheart or something like
that but they did sort of split aspects
of Lady Stoneheart storyline between
Arya who's down in the Riverlands in
Santa who took care of the Bolton's with
the help of little fingers men of the
Vale so I still think just from a visual
perspective Cersei has the coolest
looking costume but Daenerys is at least
in this promo footage is the best just
because you haven't seen a whole lot of
the ancient Targaryen in like everyone
starting to dress like their forefathers
she's starting to dress more like a
classic Targaryen so if you don't
remember all the way back to season one
we actually saw the series he dressed
kind of like this so she's dressed a
little bit like him when he thought that
he was going to become king but like you
look at these season six weirwood
visions that brain was happening
flashbacks to Jaime killing the Mad King
you can't really tell but he's wearing a
similar costume himself it's just that
it's covered up with first blood sitting
on the Iron Throne is Jaime walks up
with his sword getting ready to do the
deed but it seems like the metaphor
they're going with is the Daenerys will
be perceived as
the mad keen come again when in reality
Searcy is the mad one when you look at
all the new people that have risen to
power
Jon Snow in the North sort of left to
bang his head on the table trying to get
everyone to recognize the threat of the
white walkers and the interesting thing
about all the season 7 songs up footage
that we've seen so far is that she's
always in the godswood like she spends a
lot of time there we saw her at the end
of season 6 sitting there when
Littlefinger came to try and turn her to
his cause look I had this vision you and
me on the Iron Throne and she's like
yeah okay that's nice it's just a
fantasy and walks away but we see her
again in new season 7 footage so either
she spends a lot of time there just
thinking about her family but it would
be an interesting way for a brand to try
and make first contact with his family
again if he's not able to directly speak
to them because unless he leaves the
wall to rights out to Winterfell himself
he's going to have to find a way to
communicate very quickly with Jon Snow
and Sansa to tell them what's going on
there's a threat coming to the wall the
night king in his army are imminent and
if Sansa is near weirwood then it's much
easier for bran to try and communicate
with her but both Martin and the TV show
have been very vague about the rules of
what happens when you work into a
weirwood like you're seeing the past can
you actually talk to people
can you talk to people in the present so
they probably found an easy way around
that because you have to imagine the
level of information that bran has to
convey to Jon Snow like it would be
weird if he sent a raven where he just
said that Ned Stark isn't your father
but you have to imagine the magnitude of
the information that bran has to convey
to Jon Snow it's not something that you
would send in a simple Raven so let me
know in the comments do you think the
brand immediately ride south for a
Winterfell or do you think he finds some
other way to communicate all these
things that he's learned - jon snow and
salsa they've been dropping all this
weird roundabout promo footage they're
probably going to be something more in
the next couple of weeks as we get
closer or actually start promoting it so
we might get that first real trailer in
the next month or two and there was a
Dragonstone video that I was going to do
before this drop so that'll be my next
game of Thrones bonus video leave all
your requests in the comments below
there's a new round of the giveaway
happening it's for a copy of one of the
enhanced editions of the books all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last week's winner an
Aussie - please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details bunch of cool stuff
today that I'll talk about in that top
comment I always pin my top comment for
announcements so while you wait for that
to post you can click here to watch that
season 7 trailer again and you can click
here for brand new Rick and Morty thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video